los unió el objetivo de deshacerse de
netanyahu ahora que ya no está
empieza el trabajo real de encontrar
puntos en común el primer reto de la
nueva coalición será aprobar un nuevo
presupuesto en sus primeros 100 días si
no alcanzan un acuerdo la que en ese del
parlamento israelí se disolverá y el
país deberá ir a elecciones una vez más
el hombre al frente del ministerio de
finanzas es a víctor liberman y no se le
conoce precisamente por ser una voz de
calma
se espera que la coalición se centre en
la recuperación económica del país tras
la pandemia de coronavirus especialmente
porque es una de las cuestiones en la
que todos los partidos pueden ponerse de
acuerdo israel tiene una de las campañas
de vacunación más avanzadas del mundo
ahora los parlamentarios quieren
traducir este éxito en crecimiento
económico
la nueva coalición es la más diversa de
la historia de israel con partidos de
derecha e izquierda y partidos árabes
eso dificulta encontrar una voz común
para negociar el conflicto palestino el
mismo benet se opone abiertamente a la
solución de dos estados su partido ya
mina apoya la construcción de colonias
israelíes en los territorios palestinos
ocupados así que por ahora es improbable
que la política israelí sobre el
conflicto palestino cambie